[Music]
it's et's late-night roundup your quick
catch up on all the best celebrity scoop
after dark
my way on The Late Late Show with James
Corden Thomas sadoski announced some
exciting news he and Amanda Seyfried
secretly tied the knot Sunday we eloped
we just took off into the country with
um with uh with an officiant and just
the two of us and we did our thing
she's the person that you know I love
admire respect most in the world and did
you write your own vows yeah it was
beautiful it was everything that it
should be it was just the two of us
talking to each other and the couple are
expecting their first child together any
day now my kids I told them about this
yeah I said you so when you grow up
you're gonna marry Jimmy Fallon's
daughters it's gonna be great and they
were like mmm we have a few questions
okay so they they literally gave me a
list of questions to ask Elizabeth Banks
was a guest on The Tonight Show with
Jimmy Fallon Thursday where she
hilariously hammered the late-night host
with some pretty adorable questions from
her son's five-year-old Felix and
four-year-old Magnus Winnie does she
have a job
unfortunately no okay a tough year yeah
has she ever been electrocuted probably
she will say no but if she does say yes
I say I don't believe it a very smart
boy she's not gonna LexA katha JJ Abrams
was also a guest and his sit-down went
terribly wrong the actors from JJ's new
Broadway show the play that goes wrong
came out to sabotage the interview in
the most hilarious way we're just doing
this summer paper you a BB be a desk
desk
you'd ask I just need my my stuff yeah
thank you just can you arch your back
[Music]